Well, on a break from chemo, do you think I would benefit from taking a daily binder?
Yeah, I think it would be good for everybody to be taking a binder
Do they need to take it daily all the time not necessarily depends on if they're in remission or not
What's the purpose of a binder technically a binder is something that you're not really absorbing it stain and you're got and
And it's binding things in your
Your large intestine primarily so that you don't re-absorb them so that you then will
finish the detoxification process and
dump those things in the toilet. So remember what your liver is detoxifying and
Getting things you're filtering your blood. Anything's out of your blood
It puts it into the bile and then the bile is deposited it deposited in the first part of the small intestine called the Duwanda
Then it has to go 30 feet before it gets into the toilet and
There's times as it goes those 30 feet if we have like you got issues if we have a very slow
Tested a transit time that we have the possibility of reabsorbing those toxins that deliver work so darn hard
Getting rid of and then we reabsorb it. It goes black with the bloodstream and then our liver sees it again
It goes what in the world are you doing here again didn't I dump you three days ago and it goes has to go through the process again
Well, I don't know if the liver really does, but we don't want that to happen. So the benefit of using
Using binders now technically we get binders at our food if we're eating fiber
Fiber is a binder so it grabs out of things it keeps you from
Reabsorbing it. It's not digestible. So indigestible fiber is a binder and then you
You it goes out in the waste and you deposit it into the toilet
so
There is an athero with using a binder even when you're on chemo
Some people will say no you shouldn't use a binder when you're on chemo because you could bind the chemo
You could you could lose the benefits of the chemo. Oh, no, no by definition a binder is stated your intestinal tract
If the chemo has already gone through your detoxification pathways, it is in your intestines. You want to dump it into the toilet. You've already
You've already
Detoxified it. You don't want to reabsorb it
So you could be taking a binder when you're doing chemo therapy
so
You don't need to
Only do it when you're on a break or not do it when you're not on a break
Would you do a key later when you're doing chemo therapy? Well, maybe not a key later is
You could think of it as a binder, but you're absorbing those things typically something other than a binder
It's something different that is absorbable you absorb that thing
like DMSA or
other
Different things that will grab onto stuff in the tissues in your cells and pull it out of the cells into
The blood so that you will detoxify it. Well, if you're taking a bunch of key laders
While you're doing chemo therapy, you have the potential, I guess a key lady don't the chemo and get it less benefit from the chemo
So really you get the benefit of the chemo really within the first 48 hours after
I be administration so technically you could do key laders again after 48 hours
If you're trying to key laid out other toxins in your body and you're trying to mitigate the negative effects of the chemo
That would be happening as well. So
Answer yes on this question would be appropriate